Aquí tenemos un sólido tridimensional y queremos
imaginar qué tipo de figura obtendríamos si
hiciéramos un corte vertical. Para recordar o para
darnos una idea de lo que es un corte vertical,
imaginemos que esto es un queso o algo muy suave,
pero sigue siendo un sólido tridimensional.
Digamos que hacemos un corte por aquí, tenemos
esta cosa grande y afilada de metal para cortar
por aquí, y esto es lo que voy a hacer: voy
a llevarla hasta abajo para hacer el corte
vertical del que estamos hablando. Hagamos
el objeto suficientemente grande para poder
capturar la figura que resultará del corte. Voy a
cortar, voy a ir hasta abajo y cortar este queso,
esta pirámide rectangular de queso o lo que
sea. ¿Y cuál sería la figura resultante de
la intersección entre el queso y esta cortadora
que estoy usando? Ahora los invito a pausar el
video y pensar en cuál será la figura resultante.
La figura será de dos dimensiones debido a que
esta superficie morada es bidimensional.
Podríamos verlo como parte de un plano,
de modo que estamos buscando la figura donde
esto se cruza cuando cortamos esta pirámide
rectangular. Así que los invito a pausar el video
y pensarlo por ustedes mismos, pensemos en ello.
Déjenme dibujar de nuevo la pirámide
rectangular, es la misma. Ahora veamos
cómo se ve una vez que esta cortadora llega
hasta abajo. Entonces aquí es donde corté,
corté justo aquí; luego la cortadora saldrá por la
parte inferior, el corte se verá así de este lado
y se verá así de este lado, luego saldrá por la
parte inferior. Déjenme dibujarlo todo. Entonces,
una vez que lo cortemos se verá así, este es un
corte vertical, la cortadora llegó hasta abajo,
y ahora la intersección entre la cortadora y la
pirámide va a tener justo esta figura que tenemos
aquí. Cortamos desde la parte superior justo
aquí y llegaremos hasta el fondo justo aquí,
a lo largo de este lado el corte estará aquí,
y de este lado estará, por aquí. Entonces,
¿cuál es la figura resultante en dos dimensiones
de la intersección entre la cortadora y el queso?
Bueno, será esto que parece un trapezoide,
parecería un trapezoide, de modo que esta
sería la figura resultante, la figura resultante
se vería así si hiciéramos el corte justo ahí.